هي معركه اكثر صرامه سيواجهها الجيش
الاوكراني في الشرق والهدف تحقيق مكاسب
اضافيه حيث اكدت صحيفه لان الانتصار
الميداني الذي حققه الجيش الاوكراني في
خرسون غير من الديناميكيات المتبعه في
مسار المعركه في اشاره الى ان التقدم
الاوكراني الاخير في خرسون سيسمح للجيش
الاوكراني من استهداف في خطوط الامداد
الروسيه التي تصل الى شبه جزيره القرم
والتي استولت عليها موسكو من اوكرانيا في
عام 2014 بينما لا تزال روسيا تعاني من
نقص في الافراد ومشاكل في القياده وسيكون
الجيش الاوكراني مجبرا على تحقيق مكاسب
ميدانيه وتنفيذ هجمات مضاده وانشاء خطوط
دفاعيه في دون بس بعد ان تمكن من استعادته
[موسيقى]
اصبحوا متوحشين بين الحين والاخر لكن
المدفعياتنا لا تسمح لهم بالتقاط انفاسهم
في مثل هذه اللحظات لدينا استطلاع الجوي
الخاص
لذلك نقوم بالاستطلاع اثناء القصف ونحدد
المواقع التي يطلقون النار منها
[موسيقى]